joining us back here on the program
getting settle in its 12th year in the
NFL unbelievable who was back in 2008
that he was a second round pick out of
the you and the four-time Pro Bowler
from the Jacksonville Jaguars defensive
line coleus Campbell back here on the
show how are you class oh man I can't
complain you know I'm happy to have a
job and to be playing a demo 12 years 12
years what would you tell that rookie
about the NFL that you know now so bad
you tell that right enjoy enjoy every
minute of it you know I mean I see a lot
of people come and go and you know it's
hard to get to you know 12 years in NFL
you know definitely been an incredible
ride but you know just enjoy every
minute of it look at the flashback so
where was your Brinks truck to arrive
where is your brain struck yeah that was
that was oppressive you know that was
that was funny ha ha Davis the comedian
that was doing the knife reform that's
who that was yeah he was funny you know
that guys they did I guess I did the
commercial together for adidas so that
was something juror but that's kind of
funny I should have followed the money
so this was a shoe deal situation that
they did I think so I think so but all I
know is you know do you guy Reggie Wayne
just have the better
oh yeah he really did I mean he would he
would show up you know I guess he would
show up sometimes by air by plane you
know by car I know that I know Reggie
would do that sort of thing
so do we know who told Tom Coughlin that
Jalen Ramsay was doing this do who is
that person class is that are you the
one who informs hey hey Tom guess how I
have no idea whether there is somebody
on that staff there is somebody in the
building whose job it is to tell Tom
Coughlin stuff like that right class I'm
sure I have no idea what our guys
you're dealing with different flow
charts I'm sure okay let's get into it
here what what
I guess what happened to your team last
year I mean well how would you describe
your 2018 season in Jacksonville Peleus
I was terrible you know I mean we know
big expectations and we didn't place was
wanted to but the good thing about that
is is that it was a learning experience
you know you have a young team matured a
lot you know you can see you know the
guys who are still here from that -
there's a lot of maturity a lot of
lessons being learned so you know but
these are paid dividends this year and
all this time that we had this year
especially I love the locker room right
now tell me tell me about it how is it
different really you know just a lot
more you guys are locked in you know
enough to say we were locked in master I
mean you know every year you know
there's always some battles and things
yet to go through but uh you know just
an energy and a speed we play with in
other competition you know the energy
that falls brings is very impressive -
no I mean he's he's a great competitor
now we're out there going back and forth
and I just loved the way he competes
with us know and it sucks a little trash
and you know it's definitely fun well
hold it singing because you you led me
to my next question Nick Foles talks
trash it's like the fun kind you know
you know it's definitely though you know
I mean he just reads about sciatica let
me know or you know he does a good boy
you know he's just a lucky kid and you
gotta crash it was a good ball he says
that look you know that that's just like
I would that was special but how does
having a guy who was a Super Bowl MVP at
that position you know and I know again
you know what Blake bortles meant to the
team when he was drafted there and what
they hope to have and how close you did
get to the Super Bowl that Nick Foles
one okay
that said how his foals made it
different that you have somebody that
with that steady hand and resume at that
position hilarious I think the biggest
thing is uh you know it's wisdom you
know when you you know he's a 30-year
old quarterback and me person I've been
quarterbacks are in their prime when I
disappeared you know there's some guys
who's really
early in their careers but most
quarterbacks you know my opinion when I
get to third is when you really start
understanding the game at the highest
level where you can really dissect you
know what what people do to you intact
weaknesses the differences and so when
you're out when we're out there just you
know Falls and I can tell he really
knows what we're trying to do he knows
where the weaknesses are our difference
he's really trying to exploit them and
with the dirt it makes us a lot better
because now we have to be on a stuff
about you know plant or distress proper
to protecting our weaknesses and knowing
what we need to be sharp at and you know
that when you have that you know it's
definitely a mensch up an iron we're all
better yeah crisper at the position and
maybe a little bit more
is there more respect in the locker room
a lot of respect man these guys love the
game of football and when you love the
game of football and you right they're
playing for one another
you know you built that respect you know
and each year that's something you have
to do you have to build respect and you
know as a whole you know the team has
really been you know guys occupations
are in their respect and folds
especially you know here's a guy who
came in and sat down to work you know
and just naturally you know are in the
respect of the guys in locker room well
I mean and I don't just throw that
around you know classical ice Campbell
the Jaguars I just don't throw that
around I mean look I would you know
you've been in this league again 12
years so you've seen it all last year
going into the season you know what
Jalen Ramsey had to say publicly about a
lot of other quarterbacks around the
league including his one in his locker
room set off a little bit of an alarm
bell and in in in parts of the NFL
trying to suss what the Jaguars were all
about has that all just been swept out
with the changes that were made in the
last say few months class yeah I feel
like each year you have to reestablish
you know you know who you want to be in
your identity and so you know you really
kind of start with a clean slate
and so yeah you know it's just it's a
new clean slate and you know guys came
in and really put the work there and you
know so I feel like you know I think the
energy in the locker room is better and
I mean we have a way better schedule
which I think mad after
cost
because he created a you know I mean the
last couple years or China camp was you
know I read a difference control that
was really really demanding and I think
that making these adjustments really
gave us a lot of debate coming in a lot
more fun for the guys so we're having a
great time and you can see guys really
getting better and love and being in the
locker room loving working the stuff not
too that pays big dividends interesting
so Doug Marrone has switched something
up can you give me an example of that
Elias you know was different they don't
agree but I think a lot of it is just
you know having a schedule that is a
very friendly suppose you could tell
your body you could spend more time and
locker room I think that's one thing
that they're trying to Tempest for is
just being around the guys and so we
just some Locker on Sam where we just
get the hang and and and eat together
and then you know I you know take upper
bodies you know in the cold tub share
stories you know building their bond
sometimes we're helping each other
they'll talk about plays on the field
but that time is crucial you know being
able to have that time so you know I
mean I have to take my head off to cross
Rome because you know he's always tried
to come about a coach and talk to those
players and and you know he listened to
us and sometimes she'll agree with us
and and I tell us a good idea you know
I'll look into that more at some times
but I like that you know but I suspect
you know and you built that trust
communication and it makes us a better
team well hey I mean you know look I got
a look at his confluence Giants I mean
the story goes from the first year that
they won a Super Bowl with Coughlin and
Eli is that Coughlin relaxed things just
a wee bit and and then had some sort of
you know I I guess
group of veterans that got together and
would come to him with some ideas that
players were interested in changed
things and they want a Super Bowl I mean
that happen that absolutely happened
that's a fact I know what how is for net
coleus I mean when you talk about clean
slates and and perhaps maturity is is
that a guy that you'd be referring to on
that front
energy
he's bring a lot of energy you know he's
running the ball order practice and he
comes
you know he's come to work every day
without energy which is the most in jazz
for a young player with his kind of
ability has just come to work with some
positive energy and and I when you see
him in the holes hard no better moves
you know just you know just challenging
us you know with a speed of stuff and
you know and I love this personality
when he you know gets into you know that
mode of talking trash and having a
little swagger to him and you know he's
been he's been impressive so far you
know that's a lot of battle room a lot
of time you know we have a long way to
go we're not what we want to be but you
know he's definitely impressed me a lot
of guys understand of impressed me so
you know we're exactly where we need to
be right now just gotta keep work a
couple more minutes left with Calais
Campbell of the Jacksonville Jaguars
okay so in terms of impressive one of my
favorite moments from the draft goliaths
was the snapshot of your new teammate
Josh Allen having his kid on his lap and
he's on a landline phone because he
can't be on his cell phone cuz his son
is watching a movie on it and I just
took me that was and he was all
emotional with his head touching his
son's head as his moment as he's hearing
from maybe was Tom Coughlin or Schad
Khan I don't know who it might have been
on the phone telling him that he was a
Jaguar that was just kind all kinds of
awesome okay well what what can you tell
me about this young man and how
successful he might be with you this
year starts with him just loving the
game you know you give me a guy we love
the day where we can quickly reach and
figure out how to play football the
right way you know and but he has a lot
of natural ability and you know he's a
he's a sponge for knowledge I mean he
has so many questions and I really tried
to understand the details of things and
it worked it and you know I mean today
through practice we're working on the
move and you know and I was trying to
work with him and he was you know he was
terrible at first kind of last night of
how bad he was with was trying to do and
he was like nah maybe wasn't for me but
then we got to work a little bit more
and it's like ah you know I decided
didn't feel for and you know and I think
it would be a big move for him you know
but the thing is is that he's just he's
hungry for knowledge and he's gonna put
the work in and he loves the game and
you do see them in a satellite system
he's very very blessed and so you know
I'm really looking forward to similar
des course he can definitely help us yes
and if you spoken to in Gok way anytime
lately yeah you know a guy who you know
we have a really good relationship you
know attacked a little bit you know
fairly often oh my god I know I'm
excited for you coleus I'm excited for
year 12 it's it's a it's a significant
number for you personally and then this
is a tough division that Jacksonville
could absolutely compete and win I'm
very excited for you coleus I really am
manis opportunities there just kind of
put the work in and make it happen just
knock on it all right thanks for the
call class we'll chat down the line
always a pleasure not to be right back
at you right back at you always a
pleasure one of my favorite Scalia's
campbell for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app